Guten Abend.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Eidogan.
Ich bin hier der zuständige Asthüsi und würde gerne mit Ihnen das auf Manu gespät werden.
Also das Anamnese gespät werden. Ich würde dann einverstanden.
Ja, gerne.
Ich werde zuerst einfach fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir sofort auf Ihre Beschwerden.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Jens Bauman.
Jens Bauman.
Also Jens schreibt sich mit J-E-N-S.
Jawoll.
Und Bauman, B-A-U-M-A-N, ja?
Doppelt-N.
Doppelt-N am Ende. Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Bauman?
Ich bin 43 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 4. Juli 181.
181.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m groß.
1,78 m?
70.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie zu Zeit?
Etwa 85 kg.
85 kg.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Bauman?
Ne.
Ich habe keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Ja, super.
Also wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausärztin?
Mein Hausarzt ist Doktor Raab.
Doktor Raab.
Raab, R-A-A-B.
Okay, alles klar.
Was fühlt sich zu uns, Herr Bauman?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit 3 Tagen Schmerzen
in meinem linken Torachsbereich.
Ich hatte vorher meinen Freund beim Umzug geholfen.
Einen Tag vorher.
Und am folgetag bin ich aufgestanden
und habe Schmerzen in meinem linken Brustbereich.
Hatten Sie damals Wutrein?
Nein, das war kein Trauma.
Ich war bekannt.
Könnten Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dummstechend?
Ja, so ein stechender Ziehender Schmerz.
Ungefähl in der Höhe von meiner Brust sozusagen.
Und mit meiner Brust geht es bis nach unten.
Von hinten nach vorne, so ein Ziehender Schmerz.
Okay.
Von oben bis unten.
Nicht von rundherum, sozusagen.
Ah, okay.
Das ist ein stechender Schmerz.
Also, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkörner,
wobei ein sehr leicht und sehr starken Schmerzen entspült?
Ja, das hängt davon ab.
Bei einer bestimmten Position habe ich acht ungefähr.
Aber wenn ich so sitze und laufe, dann habe ich vielleicht zwei.
Also, wenn ich nachts kann, kann ich nicht schlafen.
Wenn ich mich hinlege, ob drücken oder auf der linken Seite liegen,
habe ich Probleme.
Da wache ich manchmal auf nachts.
Okay, verstehe.
Also, ich treibe die Schmerzen in den Winfenschulte, oder Arm?
Nee, in den Arm nicht.
Würde du sagen, so in meinem Herzbereich, Doktor?
Herzbereich, okay.
Hatten Sie aber keinen Unfall, ja?
Ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Ich habe nur meinen Freund getragen,
um etwas Möbel und so weiter zu tragen.
Da haben wir viel gearbeitet.
Also, haben Sie Luftnoten?
Nein, aber wenn ich tief einatme, habe ich einen stechenden Schmerz.
Wenn ich gut da habe, habe ich Schmerzen.
Oder wenn ich tief einatme, habe ich Schmerzen.
Also, so ein stechenden Schmerz, als ob ich ein Messer wäre.
Also, haben Sie Herzgasen oder Herzstreuen?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Also, haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie mehr Schmerzen haben,
wenn Sie Husten haben?
Wenn ich da kuste oder wenn ich tief einatme,
Schmerzen mehr.
Das ist eine Zunahme da.
Atemabhängige Schmerzen, sozusagen.
Wenn ich aber nicht mehr schmerze.
Und lageabhängige Schmerzen.
Wenn ich mich auf den Rücken liege
oder nach linksseitenlage schlafen will,
wache ich auf.
Ich muss immer mich umdrehen oder hinsetzen.
Ich muss Medikament einnehmen.
Also, haben Sie welche Medikamente eingenommen dagegen?
Ja, was ich zuhause habe, ist zum Beispiel Ibuprofen
und Novalgin-Tabletten.
Also, haben diese Medikamenten bei Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, wenn ich sie genommen habe,
dann hat es mir ein bisschen die Schmerzengelindert leicht.
Ich habe es echt.
Also, Herr Baumann, haben Sie Überkeit oder Erbrechen
oder sind Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, es ist nicht.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Hausarzt?
Beim Hausarzt war ich nicht.
Nein, ich habe gedacht, es geht weg.
Okay.
Ich habe gedacht, es geht weg.
Also, haben Sie Schmerzen auch in Ruhe?
In Ruhe, leicht, ist nicht so stark.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich habe so einen ziehenden Schmerz.
Die Schmerzen, die sind von 1,5 bis 3 Tagen
ein bisschen zugegeben geworden.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich weiß nicht,
ob ich etwas im Herzen habe oder so.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst gekommen.
Ich habe gedacht, es geht weg.
Okay.
Herr Baumann, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen
oder Stullgang?
Hab ich nicht.
Haben Sie Stelpost, Nachtschweiß?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Also, haben Sie in letzter Zeit oder zugenommen?
Nein, ist normal.
Ich habe nicht.
Es ist normal,
ich bin immer so um die 85, minus 1 kg oder so.
Also, können Sie gut schlafen,
haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim...
Bist auch die letzten 3 Tage eigentlich gut schlafen.
Also, haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, Herr Baumann?
Andere Beschwerden.
Eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Wir haben alles gesprochen,
Ich denke schon, ich habe Schmerzen, die ziehen so um meinem Brustkorb herum und die ist
abhängig, lagerabhängig.
Okay, Herr Baumann, ich würde gerne jetzt einfach fragen, ob Sie die der Pfund sich
stellen.
Meiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
An chronische Erkrankungen, was meinen Sie damit?
Zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck, Erhöhnte, Fettwerte.
Ja, wegen Bluthochdruck nehme ich Medikamente ein.
Also außer Bluthochdruck, haben Sie noch andere Pfundchen vor Erkrankungen?
Nicht, dass ich schwöchste.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit zwei Jahren.
Also kontrollieren Sie Ihren Bluthochdruck regelmäßig?
Ja, regelmäßig nicht, aber ab und zu schon das merk ich.
Wenn der mal ein bisschen höher geht, merk ich, dann habe ich ein bisschen Kopfschmerz.
Aber dann nehme ich noch eine Tablette noch dazu, dann geht es.
Okay, okay.
Du hast meistens gut eingestellt, hat mein Hausarzt gut eingestellt.
Weißt du das Problem?
Also keine Schwankungen, großartige Schwankungen.
Okay, super.
Verstehe.
Also was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Also ich meine, gegen Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck nehme ich nur Ramipril ein.
Ramipril zehn Mittag, die nehme ich nur morgens ein.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente ein?
Wer gehen Sie sich oder beide da?
Nicht, bei Bedarf habe ich zu Hause also Ibuk,
wenn ich noch ihn berühren muss oder was hab ich noch zu Hause.
Eigentlich nichts.
Das war es schon.
Super.
Herr Bohrmann, sieht Sie schon einmal Uberit?
Ja, in meiner Kindheit, da war ich zehn Jahre alt, da wurde ich einem ein Mandel operiert.
Mhm.
Herr Bohrmann?
Ne, nicht, dass ich höchst du, ne.
Okay.
Herr Bohrmann, raufen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Also seit wann raufen Sie?
Ah ja, seit 20 Jahren, circa.
Seit 20 Jahren, wie viel Zigarette, wie viel Schrauben Sie?
Eine halbe Packung, kann man schon sagen, ja.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Bohrmann?
Ja, aber nur bei besonderen Anlässen, bei Gelegenheit.
Also regelmäßig.
Okay.
Was trinken Sie, wenn Sie etwas trinken möchten?
Das ist, kann mal eine Flasche Bier sein, was auf der Feier ist oder kann auch Tequila mal sein.
Mhm.
Okay.
Oder beim Abendessen mal, wo wenn ich eingeladen bin, Wein oder so.
Aber wenn ich...
Also Herr Bohrmann, nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht, Herr Bohrmann,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, Drogen, ne, ich weiß nicht mal, wie das geschrieben wird.
Ja, super.
Perfekt.
Also Herr Bohrmann, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch.
Leiden Sie an den Menschen, die von der Chronischen Erkrankung gehen?
Weiß ich nicht, also mein Vater hat, weiß ich, ob das chronische Erkrankung ist,
mein Vater nimmt Medikamente ein, ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen,
wegen Vorruf, wenn man Herz-Rhythmusstörung hat, ja.
Und meine Mutter, weiß ich, ob das eine Erkrankung ist,
ist übergewichtig und nehmt Tabletten ein wegen Ihren Zucker.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister, ich habe einen Bruder, der jünger ist als ich.
Okay, ist der gesund?
Ja, soweit ich weiß.
Herr Bohrmann, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Also haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist auch gesund, Gott sei Dank.
Was sind Sie von der Chronischen Erkrankung?
Ich bin die Vor- und mache IT-Beratung.
Ich bin die Vor- und ich bin die IT-Berater.
Herr Bohrmann, ich habe alle meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Fragen angeschlossen?
Ja, Herr Doktor, wie geht es denn weiter?
Ich habe Angst, habe ich eine Erzinfarkt oder ist etwas,
wie sich schmerzen, können Sie mir helfen?
Was wird es jetzt gemacht? Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Also, ja, ich kann Ihre Sorgen verstellen, Herr Bohrmann.
Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, bitte.
Also vermutlich haben Sie eine Defend-Fraktöre
also die Muskelris.
Aber das ist eine Not-Affirmutung.
Um meinen Verdacht ja nur dazu zu stellen,
muss ich erst mal Sie für völlig untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen, dann einfach Massnahmen duschen.
Zum Beispiel Röntgen, Torachs und so weiter.
Dann kann ich Ihnen mehr sagen, was Sie genau haben.
Was wird jetzt gemacht? Es wird gerünscht.
Gerünscht, Torachs.
Also ich würde gerne eine EKG machen.
Also ich würde gerne auch Ultraschall machen.
Okay.
Kann man auch etwas mit Blut sehen?
Kann man vielleicht mit einer Bluthüter-Sorge machen?
Ja, ja, ich habe schon das gesagt.
Also ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Okay, okay.
Nach der Ergebnisse, also informiere ich Ihnen Schritt durch Schritt.
Was machen wir?
Röntgen-Untersuchung, was ist das eigentlich?
Ich höre das immer röntgen, aber ich wurde nie gerünscht.
Also das ist ein Bildgewendungsverfahren.
Also mit Hilfe der Röntgen-Strahlung
bekommen wir ein Bild, also von Torachs Abdoumen,
also Kopf oder weiter.
Torachs oder Abdoumen, was ist das?
Ich meine Brust oder Bauch oder Kopf.
Dann können wir mit dieser Methode die Beine
beurteilen, ob es Frachtöre gibt, also Bruch gibt.
Ist es eine schädliche Untersuchung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine schädliche Untersuchung ist, deswegen frage ich.
Also Sie bekommen Röntgen-Strahlung,
aber es ist sehr gering, es macht keinen Sinn,
also machen Sie sich eben, deswegen keine Sorgen.
Was ist gering? Ein zu 100 oder ein zu 1000, ein zu einer Million?
Was meinen Sie mit gering, gering ist vielleicht zu viel für mich,
weil sich nichts, ich bin ein bisschen unsicher.
Okay, also ich kann Ihnen so beschreiben, es ist wie ein Transatlantikflug.
Was meinen Sie mit einem Transatlantikflug?
Also wenn Sie mit einem Flugzeug, also 3 oder 4 Stimmen,
fliegen, können Sie gleiche Röntgen-Strahlung bekommen.
Also ich meine so.
Ach so, wenn ich im Flugzeug bin, bekomme ich auch Strahlen.
Ja, aber da werde ich doch nicht gerünscht.
Da werde ich doch nicht gerünscht.
Wo kommen die Strahlen denn her?
Wenn ich im Flugzeug bin.
Also ich habe Ihnen Akustik nicht gerünscht.
Also meine im Flugzeug werde ich da gerünscht.
Sind da auch Röntgen-Geräte, deswegen gibt es Strahlen
oder was für Strahlen sind das?
Nein, also ich meine die Strahlen kommen.
Ich kenne mich da nicht aus.
Ja, okay, also die Strahlen kommt aus der Sonne, also aus der Sonne.
Aus dem All.
Aus dem All, okay.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Frühjahre beschwerden?
Nein, solcher Schmerzen hatte ich nicht gehabt bis jetzt.
Zweite Frage ist, machen Sie die Strahlen,
die Sie in der Sonne haben?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Zweite Frage ist, machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Sport.
Ich fahre öfters Fahrrad und hobbymäßig.
Ich fahre viel Fahrrad.
Ansonsten, in meiner Jugend habe ich Fußball gespielt
und Volleyball gespielt.
Ansonsten die letzten 15 Jahre, bestimmt nicht.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es eine Fahrveränderung der Haupt in betroffenen Bereichen?
Nein, ich habe keine Hauptveränderung bemerkt.
Haben Sie im betroffenen Bereich Type-Heiß geführt
oder Triebberg geführt?
Misse-Empfindungen habe ich auch nicht bemerkt.
Nein, danke.
Einige haben sich in der Übersicht gefragt?
Ja, sie haben es gefragt.
Ein Impfpunkt, nicht geimpft.
Ein Impfpunkt?
Ein Impfpunkt, ich bin wegen allen Sachen geimpft,
sei es Tätanus oder Corona.
Einige haben gesagt, es geht auslöse,
aber ich habe eine Frage,
ob ich es auf den
Tag nach dem Tragen habe.
Ich hatte vor vier Tagen meinen Freund geholfen,
beim Umzug, beim Möbel.
Da war an dem Tag nichts.
Ich bin normal nach Hause gegangen, habe geschlafen.
Und morgens beim Aufstehen habe ich die Schmerzen bemerkt.
Diese Schmerzen habe ich versucht mit Medikament,
Ibuprofen genommen, habe dich gereicht,
dann habe ich bei Bedarf noch eine Walgi genommen.
Aber in den letzten drei Tagen hat es zugenommen.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen strahlen nach...
Also im linken Brustkopf,
das ist irgendwie mein ganzer linker Brustkopf,
von hinten nach vorne oder vorne nach hinten,
habe ich einen Schmerz.
Zieh den Schmerz.
Nach hinten nach oben, oder?
Nein.
Es ist so um mein Herz herum, habe ich das Gefühl.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestellt, Herr Jan.
Sind gestellt, ja.
Sind gestellt.
Oder wurde gestellt, glaube ich, das ist besser.
Ja, aber unsere Kollegen haben eine Unterbindung gemacht,
weil der Patient Nikotin Abousius hat,
und eine familiäre Position für die Akutkorner Senderung.
Und man nicht und 43 Jahre alt.
Können wir als Herz gesprungen fangen, Adiosmann?
Ja, können wir.
Also ich bin so fit.
Okay.
Ich habe Probleme beim Herz-Härts-Gispring, aber...
Also, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen,
wenn ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Voll, deswegen bin ich da, bitte.
Schießen Sie los.
Okay, also Herr Jens Bauman ist ein 43-jähriger Patient,
1,78 m groß und 5,80 kg schwer.
Also Herr Bauman stellte sich heute wegen
seit 3 Tagen bestehende, ziehende, stechende, zunehmende
Torachschmerzen links mit Australien zum Herzbereich.
Ja, also bei uns vor.
Der Patient berichtete,
dass er beim Umzug seinem Freund geholfen hat.
Dabei, also damals, hat er die Torachschmerzen.
Am nächsten Tag, am Folgetag?
Folgende Tag, ja richtig.
Folgende Tag hat er Torachschmerzen gehabt.
Also die Schmerzintensität wurde, also wurde in Ruhe mit 2,8
und also bei...
2,10.
3,10?
3,10, sorry.
3,10 und bei bestimmter Lage zum Beispiel,
also linker Seite legen zum Beispiel mit 8,10 berichtet.
Also desweiteren, er hat das er mehr schmerzen hat,
wenn er puste, oder tief atme, tief einatme.
Okay.
Ich habe ja nicht gesagt Rotation.
Es ist bewegungsabhängig, kann man sagen,
und bei linksseitenlage, also wenn ich auf der linken Seite liege,
dann bewege ich ja den Torachs.
Wie schreiben wir Inspiration und bei Bewegung?
Inspiration und bei bestimmten Bewegungen.
Wenn man fragt, bei welchen Bewegungen,
und zwar bei linksseitenlage und rückenlage,
hat er Schmerz-Zunahme.
Bei bestimmte Positionen, oder?
Genau, bei bestimmte Positionen kann man auch sagen,
aber wenn man dann fragt, dann fragt man,
bei welcher Position, ja, wenn er auf der linken Seite liege,
linksseitenlage, oder auf rückenlage beim Liegen.
Nachts steht er halt auf und hat sich hinsetzen,
oder den Oberkörper nach oben aufrecht beenden.
Auf Nachfrage wurden Unfall, also Dispne, Tachycardi, tennein.
Also gegen die Schmerzen hat er zu Hause Ibuprofen
und Novalgin eindäumen, aber das hat ihm wenig geholt.
Also in der vegetative Anamnense leitet er unter Schlaflosigkeit,
also beschwerde Abhängige Schlafstörungen.
Also in den letzten drei Tagen, vorher nicht?
Ja, in den letzten drei Tagen.
Also einzige bekannte Vorerkrankung ist Arterielehyperkonik seit zwei Jahren
und dagegen nimmt er Rami Pril zehnmigramm einmal morgens.
Also in der Kindheit wurde eine Tolsillektomie
bei den Patienten vorgenommen.
Also er hat Komplikation gehabt bei der Operation damals?
Ja, ich habe das nicht gefragt.
Okay, das können Sie nachher, wenn Sie den Patienten nochmal sehen,
nochmal fragen.
Ja, okay, unbedingt werde ich das fragen.
Okay, danke.
Also er hat seit 20 Jahren Halbepackung gelegt
und trinkt Alkohol gelegentlich
und Drogenkonsum wurde verleinert.
Also in der Familienanamnense ergab
bei der Mutter Diabetes Melitis und
Adipositas beim Vater Hochof Lümer.
Er hat einen Bruder, aber er ist gesund.
Als sozialanamnistisch ist er verheiratet, hat eine Tochter,
gesundes Tochter und also er ist IT Beraterkombin.
Also nach dem anamnistischen Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht
auf Ribbenfraktur, linkseitiger Ribbenfraktur.
Aber eine Frage, Sie sagten, er ist nicht gestürzt.
Woher kann diese Fraktur kommen?
Er ist 45 Jahre alt.
Wie kommt die Ribbenfraktur?
Sie haben einen Trauma.
Ja, ich dachte, das...
Sie könnte sein, warum nicht?
Das ist eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Wie wird es genauer heißen?
Also pathologische Fraktur.
Ja, das kann man als Verdachtdiagnose sagen.
Er ist raucher, vielleicht hat er einen Lungenkarzinom
und eine Pesthase und das weiß ich schon alles.
Pathologische Ribbenfraktur kann sein, okay.
Aber sonst ist es ein sonderer Mensch,
warum soll er eine Ribbe kaputt sein?
Oder er hat vielleicht eine Osteoporose,
kann auch logisch sein.
Na ja, okay.
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen denken Sie?
Was kann es sonst sein?
Also es kann noch in Discos Prolapse,
in Thoracalbibern,
in Brustgebelsäulen-Bereich.
Ja, Brustgebelsäulen-Bereich.
Es kann noch Muskelris sein.
Eine Muskelris, dafür muss man riesen Trauma haben,
aber eine Muskelzehrung vielleicht.
Ja, Muskelzehrung.
Vielleicht besser als Ris.
Ja, okay.
Den Bereich, den zwei Ribben nennt man wie,
die sind bereich.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Beide Ribben, eine Ribbe.
Interkostal.
Interkostal, genau.
Wenn man da Schmerzen hat, wie nennt man das?
Interkostalschmerzen.
Ne, Schmerz heißt Algi, aber Neuralgi zum Beispiel.
Interkostal-Neuralgi kann es zum Beispiel auch sein.
Interkostal-Neuralgi.
Ja.
Ja, also auch sein.
Genau.
Was kann es sonst sein?
Also, ich würde sagen,
das ist meistens das andere.
Nach meiner Meinung, viele geben zwar irgendeine Diagnose
in den Krankenhäusern, aber nach meiner Meinung
würde es etwas sein, wenn es ein atemabhängiger Schmerz ist.
Also, wenn ich tief einatme, was bewegt sich am meisten,
wenn ich tief einatme?
Also, wo meinet ihr die Erklartmars?
Knöchern.
Es gibt ja etwas, also der Zwergschel arbeitet.
Zwergschel, okay.
Ja, und was arbeitet noch, wenn ich tief einatme?
Was arbeitet noch?
Automatisch.
Rungen.
Ne, ja, auf, weiter.
Das sind beide Teile. Knöchern.
Was ist das?
Ja, die Rippen arbeiten.
Wenn sie tief einatmen, arbeiten die Rippen.
Um eine Rippel zu bewegen,
was braucht es?
Einem Gelenk.
Ja.
Ich habe eine Kostowertabral-Gelenkblockade
oder eine Gelenkreizung sein, zum Beispiel.
Also, Kostowertabrale.
Kostowertabrale, also Rippen,
Wirbelkörper, also Wirbelkörper,
auf Lateinisch, Kostowertabrale,
Gelenk,
oder eine Gelenkblockade sein.
Blockiertes Rippengelenk,
weil eine Rippe ist ja nicht ein Organistativ,
also ganz, nicht sich bewegt,
sondern die Rippen bewegen sich.
Wenn sich etwas bewegt, muss ein Gelenk sein.
Dieser Gelenk ist an der Wirbelsäule,
Brustwirbelsäule, hinten,
und er kann nach vorne ausstrahlen, sozusagen.
Also, ich wusste nicht, ob ich das habe.
Ich wusste nicht, ob es diese Krankheit gibt.
Es gibt ja, kein Problem.
Aber es sind sehr oft Patienten,
die gehen in Notfallammerlands, da wird EKG gemacht,
da wird Troponin abgenommen,
da wurde geguckt, die sagen, Kardäologie sieht aus,
und dann werden die entlassen.
Dann landen die bei mir.
Und dann untersuche ich die und gucke, Paravirta-Bral,
ob da Schmerzen sind. Ja, besonders an der Rippe.
Dann ist es in der Rippe, die 5. Rippe, 7. Rippe,
wenn ich die drücke, also ein Druckschmerz an den Rippen,
und dann kann man schon sagen,
natürlich kann man sagen, es ist eine Fraktur,
pathologische Fraktur, kann sein, meistens nicht.
Meistens ist es eine Blockade
oder Gelenkreizung dieser Rippe.
Und dann therapiere ich das,
komme mal nachher dazu, therapiert man das,
und das wird gut, zumindest bei mir, wenn die zu mir kommen.
Aber müssen wir natürlich
Herz betrugt werden?
Ja, und ich sage auch zu meinen Patienten, meistens,
bitte, sollte erster Kardäologisch abgeklärt sein,
weil, wenn es eine Kostowerklabra Blockade
oder interkostalne Reile ist,
das kann man warten, daran schreibt man nicht.
Aber wenn es mit Herzen ist, der Herz wartet nicht.
Deswegen kann man erst den Herz abklären.
Wenn es abgeklärt ist, dann natürlich, wenn der Patient erst bei mir ist,
dann untersuche ich den schnell.
Aber wenn ich denke, ich weiß es nicht,
dann sage ich, gehen Sie direkt zum Kardäologen oder zum Krankenhaus,
oder eine andere Abteilung.
Könnten Sie bitte einmal abklären, ob das, was der Herz zu tun hat.
Aber wenn ich da sicher bin, wenn ich untersuche,
Paraveterweiler Schmerz, Druckschmerz, Herz ist ja nicht
hinten, sondern ventral mehr.
Wenn es dann zu da passt, dann kann man den therapieren.
Aber wenn man ein bisschen unsicher ist,
oder wenn jemand noch nicht bei mir ist, dann sage ich,
frage ich immer, waren Sie beim Kardäologen?
Das ist wichtig, weil diese ganzen Symptome können trotzdem
auftreten, wenn man kardiale Probleme hat,
oder Perigatitis hat oder so was, was ich hatte.
Kann man alles, kann man theoretisch auch haben.
Also müssen wir das wegen MRT nicht?
Nein, MRT nicht, sondern da sieht man das nicht unbedingt.
Also ja, man kann einmal Lungenrenken,
also Torraxaufnahme machen, man kann
knöcheln Torraxaufnahme machen, ob da eine Rüppenfraktik ist,
um auszuschließen, ob da kein Pneu ist, oder irgendwas
pathologisches ist.
Wenn das nicht ist, natürlich, was Sie vorhin gesagt haben,
EKG ist wichtig, Laborabnahme bezüglich generell,
kleines Blutbild, CRP, Ellyte, Kreia,
Gerünungsstatus und, was man noch machen kann,
die Leberenzyme sozusagen. Also die Leber, sage ich,
Herzentzyme, CK, CK-1B, Troponin und so weiter.
Also könnte es spontan, oder normal Torraxaufnahme sein,
ich meine.
Kann auch sein, natürlich kann schon sein,
spontan für Eure Raucht, deswegen kann es auch sein,
das stimmt, aber er hat keinen Dispel,
er hat nur, was klassisch ist, ist, wenn er tief
einatmet, es schmerzt. Dann ist meistens,
mit den Rippengelenken, hat es denke ich,
nach meiner Meinung zu tun. Oder manchmal ist
es auch nicht die Rippengelenke, sondern die Nerven
unter der Rippe laufen, die sind auch entzündlich gereizt,
deswegen nennt man das dann interkostale Neuralgie.
Ich interkostale Neuralgie, tritt den auch gut auf,
Hujan?
Ach gut, ich denke schon, weiß ich nicht, müsste ich passen,
aber ich denke, die können, weil der Patient hat ja nicht
gesagt, es ist 3 Uhr heute Nachmittag passiert,
sondern am nächsten Tag ist es passiert.
Das heißt, über die Nacht, dann so kann das bei
einem Patient ja auch sein.
Meine Patienten sagen, ich hatte, heute glaube ich,
oder gestern, einen Patienten, der hat gesagt,
ich musste etwas halten, die ganze Zeit, eine Lampe
oder irgendwas, halten, helfen.
Und der hat eine Tuasionsbewegung gehabt,
an der Brustkopf und länger gehalten und geholfen.
Und danach hat er nicht direkt danach,
aber danach hat er die Schmerzen gehabt, zum Beispiel.
Es gibt verschiedene Versionen.
Beim Umzug ist ja nicht so, dass er sich einfach was
hochhebt, weil dann dreht man sich, hebt man etwas hoch.
Das sind sehr viele Bewegungen, komplexe Abläufe.
Deswegen kann man nach so einem Umzug so was haben.
Oder nach einem starken Husten kann man auch so was haben.
Wenn ich Husten Erkältung habe, aber das ist ja nicht,
ich habe ja vorher nichts gesagt, zum Beispiel,
dann kann auch so ein Reckengelenkproblem sein.
Bei einer Nervenblockade.
Gelenkblockade, ich würde sagen Nervenblockade,
ich weiß nicht, ob das immer so stimmt.
Ein Nervenblockade ist für mich eine Traumatisierung des Nerven,
dass er sehr fest drückt.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, weil das heilt ja danach.
Weil ein Nerven, wenn der richtig kaputt gedrückt wird,
dann haben sie irgendwelche Entweder-Missempfindungen.
Es arbeitet dein Nerven nicht mehr.
Und deswegen bündelt sich diese Nerven-Einklemmung
oder Nerven-Zerkwetschung eher nicht.
Nervenreizung würde ich sagen, zum Beispiel durch Bandscheimvorfall.
Der Nervenwurzel kann durch Bandscheibe gereizt sein.
Als Reaktion kann der Körper muskulär anspannen
und auch diese Probleme aussehen.
Das haben Sie auch vorhin gesagt,
im Bandscheimvorfall könnte es auch machen.
Das stimmt.
Kann auch.
Es ist wichtig, aber in diesem Fall,
die Hypostesie, Parästhesie zu fragen.
Ja, warum nicht?
Man kann ja zum Beispiel,
eine andere Differenzialdiagnose,
das kann es auch sein, Gürtelrose.
Ja, stimmt.
Kokon hatte, aber dann ist so Hyperesthesie.
Das heißt sehr empfindliche Bereiche.
Ich kann nicht berühren, ich bin sehr weh.
Generell fragt man immer,
die Peripherre durch Blutung,
durch Blutung, okay, in dem Bereich
kann man Hautveränderungen usw. fragen.
Ob ein Durchblutungsproblem ist,
habe ich nie gesehen, kann aber trotzdem passieren.
Aber die anderen Sachen, also Motorik,
also kann er atmen, also Motorik ist ja da.
Und Sensibilität.
Sensibilität ist halt Missempfindung
oder Hyper-Sensibilität sozusagen.
Hyper-Hyperesthesie,
oder Hypersthesie sozusagen, glaube ich.
Also, oder gibt es da Bläschen,
kleine, kleine Blasen, gibt es Rötungen,
dann ist das eine.
Mit dem, wer ist das nochmal?
Das ist nochmal Zostervirus, glaube ich.
Also, Görtelruse, ich weiß nicht,
den da tainischen Begriff dafür.
Die können auch, Görtelruse.
Zona zoster.
Zumba, Beispiel.
Kann das sein,
eine Sternekostalgelenke
oder Kostelkonflikt?
Kann auch sein, es kann auch vom Stern
und vom Vorne dem Gelenk, also eine Sternekostalgelenkrei
zum Lokal des Landes sein.
Kann auch sein, natürlich.
Das kann von hinten nach vorne oder vorne nach hinten austrahlen.
Von Ventral nach Kostal oder von dausern nach Ventral.
Also, bei diesem Fall
muss ich Spaß machen.
Also, ich meine,
ich muss den Patienten
zum
erstmal Kardiologen beweisen
oder zum Orthopäden beweisen.
Eigentlich,
wenn man im Krankenhaus diese Unterschiede hat, beides.
Ich würde trotzdem als Erstes,
wenn Sie
in der Zentrale sitzen und überweisen wollen,
wenn Sie Hausarztin machen,
sind Sie internist. Dann müssen Sie nicht zum Kardiologen.
Sie können selber Labo abnehmen,
EKG-Lies, also der Basis, kann auch der Hausarzt machen.
Wenn Sie im Krankenhaus sind, dann ist der Patient
entweder bei den Kardiologen oder bei den Orthopäden-Unfallschruben.
Meistens landen die, weil links oder kalle Schmerz in den Krankenhaus landen die bei den
Internisten erstmal.
Der Internist sagt meistens, dass die Realität sozusagen,
hier ist jetzt eine Stimulation von Sprachprüfung.
Aber in der Realität wird die Schwestern,
die machen eine Triage.
Meistens, nicht die Ärzte, sondern eine erfahrene Schwestern
oder Pfleger sagt dann, was haben Sie links oder kalle Schmerz?
Er ist internistisch. Erst wenn der Internist sagt,
wir haben ausgeschlossen, Kardiol ist alles okay,
gehen Sie bitte zu den Unfallschirurgen.
Meistens sind die Triage, dass die links oder kalle Schmerz,
wenn er zum Orthopäden kommt, zum Beispiel in meiner Praxis,
der sagt dann, ja, ich war schon beim Kardiologen
im Krankenhaus, haben die alles geguckt,
ich hätte mein Herz wäre alles gut, sozusagen.
Aber dann bin ich halt dran.
Dann kommen die zu mir, da sage ich,
ich suche, so wie geht es dann weiter?
Das heißt, was macht man in dem Bereich?
Ganz einfach, was macht Orthopäde immer?
Was kann man für Therapie machen?
Also, Physiotherapie meinungssinn?
Ne, also, die Therapie kriegt der Termin in 2, 3 Wochen.
Was macht der für 3 Wochen?
Ja, dann ist es ein Privatpatient,
vielleicht findet er in einer Woche oder einen Tag Wasser.
Aber Physiotherapie, nach meiner Meinung,
macht Physiotherapie die Schmerz nicht weg,
sondern da ist ein Schmerz, meistens eine Information.
Also, was gibt man?
Informatorische Medikation, was kann man geben?
Eine Argentifon.